بلا شك انه منذ اليوم الاول لهذه الماساه
حقيقه وهذه التطورات الخطيره اقليميا
ودوليا كان الموقف القطري واضح انه يجب ان
يتم احتواء هذه الازمه باسرع وقت ممكن
التسرب الاقليمي لهذه الازمه والتوسع
الاقليمي لهذه الازمه لن يكون له من اثر
الا مزيد من التوتر على مستوى الاقليم
ودوليا ولذلك عملت قطر منذ اليوم الاول في
جهود الوساطه بالتواصل ليس فقط مع طرفي
النزاع ولكن مع الاطراف الاقليميه
والدوليه المختلفه و هتم كيف ان الجهود
القطريه لم تتوقف في احلك الاوقات بما في
ذلك ما يجري في هذه الايام سواء من خلال
الاتصالات او الزيارات او المبادرات التي
قدمت في اطار انهاء هذه الحرب ونحن نعتقد
يقينا بان كل هذه التوترات الاقليميه التي
ذكرتها هي فرع من اصل والاصل هو ايقاف هذه
الحرب وبالتالي لا يمكن ان نتحدث عن حل
لكل هذه التوترات اذا تجاهلنا وضع الحرب
في غزه المجتمع الدولي مطالب اليوم اذا
كان هناك رغبه حقيقيه فيان لا يكون هناك
توترات اقليميه على مستوى ما يحدث في
البحر الاحمر او ما يحدث في العراق او ما
يحدث في غيرها من المواقع اقليميا مطالب
بان يتخذ قرارا واضحا في الضغط لايقاف هذه
الحرب فورا وليس الحديث عن تمكين لاستمرار
هذه الحرب من
خلال الغاء انسانيه الفلسطيني وتحويل هذه
المساله لمساله يعني لا يمكن تعامل معها
الا من خلال هذه الصوره التي نراها اليوم
على الشاشات من القتل والدمار اليومي
الذي يستهدف انسانيتنا جميعا وبالتالي
الحديث حقيقه عن كل ما يحدث في المنطقه
كما قال معالي لا شك ان ما يحدث البحر
الاحمر يمثل خطوره على الملاحه الدوليه
ويمثل قلق بالنسبه لكل الدول التي تعتمد
على خطوط الملاحه هذه وقطر من الدول اللي
تعتمد عليها بشكل كبير جدا طبعا في
صادراتها من من قطاع الطاقه وفي وارداتها
من العالم كله ولكن لا يمكن التعامل مع
هذه المساله كانها منفصله تماما وبشكل
معزول تماما عن الحرب في في غزه وتطوراتها
العمل يجب ان ينصب هناك توسع في الحلول
الامنيه ايضا هو مشكله كما قال معاليه في
جلسته اليوم في في دافس هذه المساله لن
تحل بشكل عسكري امني هي ستحل بشكل سياسي
من خلال ايقاف الحرب في في غزه وبقيه هذه
التداعيات ستتراجع بناء على ذلك تستمر
الجهود القطريه هذه الايام من خلال
الاتصالات مع مختلف الاطراف نحن على امل
ان يكون هناك تقدم في هذه المفاوضات في
الايام القادمه الوضع كما تعلمون هو صعب
بشكل كبير هناك جزئيات يتم التفاوض عنها
حاليا الان على امل ان يكون هناك تطورات
ايجابيه وستعلن عننا ان شاء الله في حال
كلله هذه المحاولات بنجاح
انور السلام عليكم عندي سؤال اول بالنسبه
للنقل في البحر الاحمر في معلومات انه
استانفت قطر تسير ناقلات الغاز هل تستطيع
ان تؤكد لنا انه تم استئناف الخمس ناقلات
اللي كانت متوقفه استانفت
العمل او البحار في البحر الاحمر هذا
السؤال الاول السؤال الثاني كان هناك في
معلومات الاسبوع الماضي تتحدث عن مبادره
قطريه با اطار المفاوضات تتعلق بادخال
الادويه
للاسرى
الاين مقابل ادخال ادويه للفلسطينيين في
مستشفيات تمت هذه المبادره انجزت يعني او
الى ا لم تنجز حتى الان شكرا شكرا انور
بالنسبه لناقلات الغاز لا يمكني حقيقه
تاكيد هذه المعلومات واتركها لجهات مختصه
في في قطر للطاقه و ولديهم اكيد المعلومات
التفصيليه بهذا الشان بالنسبه لسؤالك
الثاني كما تعلمون هذه التقارير تحدثت عن
وجود هذه المفاوضات نعم هذه المفاوضات هي
قائمه وال العمل الجاري مع جميع الاطراف
لم يتم شيء حتى الان فيما يتعلق بتنفيذ
هذا الاتفاق او الوصول الى الى اتفاق ونحن
على امل ان يكون هناك تطورات ايجابيه فيه
ولكن لا يوجد لدينا اي اي تحديث فيما
يتعلق بهذا بهذا الامر